ok
alright
be patient okay cool I'm officially on
the screen now except my chats not
showing up why is it not showing up okay
let's redo this
there we go cool okay I was trying to
figure out why the chat wasn't coming up
I was like what in the world is going on
like it's weird so I use AKG headphones
okay so here's like how Alexa coffee we
are officially live got it'll be a
little quiet it's like ten o'clock I
don't want to wake the neighbors let so
anyway mine is locked up gotta refresh
oh yeah finally got to check this out
live yeah so as normal with our
collection coffee if you guys will
notice down the description we have a
link to nerd hype which is a channel
that I've chosen from the weekly poll
net to basically give people a shout out
for if you guys want to want to do it go
ahead and check them out let it let me
know what you think say hey you know
like Rob sent me here and they'll be
like yay you know and and it'll be cool
so anyway um yeah that's that's the
basis behind that you know I try to
stick with channels that are doing
something interesting doing something
new things that haven't necessarily been
seen before the other thing is yes
Disney miss me I had a clip in my
ant-man trailer and that clip got
blocked by Disney which means my video
got blocked and I thought about me i'm
not going to do another review um I mean
I made two reviews but here's a problem
with doing reviews I don't just like
sitting in front of a camera be like hey
guys so I went to see ant-man and it was
really cool like this was cool I mean I
don't like that the videos I don't want
to do it everybody else does I don't
want to do what everybody else has done
like I want to do something different
something unique something totally
separate you know if I can't if I end up
having to do what everybody else does to
me there's no point in doing it but you
know nonetheless yes it's a personal
preference i'll probably still do
reviews and i'll probably end up just
sitting in this chair and being like hey
guys i saw the movie it was cool but you
know i mean it's it's all good i'll have
to find a more creative way to create my
reviews which is fine because creativity
is what inspires innovation so not a bad
thing got a bad thing but anyway um
let's see hey Robert you sign up for the
preview program for xbox one yet I don't
know what that is what's the
preview program John sweden's action was
actually pretty solid asana she xmen was
not bad at all um where's there's his
gorgeous baldish head where's the phone
I'm not bringing back to throw no I
don't know what the preview program is
that sounds cool it sounds interesting
but no I have no idea what that is Rob
what's your favorite movie Batmobile
definitely from the Dark Knight because
it seems more like I don't know it seems
a more functional it seems more it seems
more like what you would see in the real
world and I like that idea i mean if i
wanted to see as here's the kicker what
a lot of people say you know I was like
well this is not let's not like it is in
the comic so I don't understand you know
I know it's in the comics I've seen
what's of the comics because I've been
reading the comics I don't want what
I've already seen I want something new I
want a different take and that's why I
liked the dark knight you know because
it was it was different you know the
whole like Christopher Nolan real world
Batman was an element that I loved
because I know the comic Batman I've
been reading the comic Batman for years
like I know what that Batmobile looks
like I know what that bat suit looks
like you know and so um so I dig it you
know it's their beta testing program for
new apps and yeah okay yeah no I'm not
I'm not worried about that so what were
your top five favorite Marvel storylines
who probably Civil War number one number
two would be infinity gauntlet number
through the age of Ultron number four
would be House of M and number five hmm
probably the dark knight returns from
Frank Miller that was really solid like
I really dug yet although I will say
this reading the current run of Superman
like Geoff Johns Superman which is
basically the pre loop to Superman truth
I'm really enjoying that like I'm really
enjoying the whole Superman truth thing
I think it's actually pretty amazing um
honestly I have not read a Superman
story that was this compelling at a long
time that being said geoff johns brought
a lot to the green lantern series and I
still haven't read Geoff Johns Green
Lantern epic all the way through so i
probably should
and having said that I think it'll I
think it'll turn out to be a pretty
solid thing up a whole pretty solid
thing um let's see I agree it's always
nice to have a new spin on things
exactly of interest is a simple is
pretty good but the problem with
Avengers disassembled is that you know
it's is a prelude basically it's a lead
up to the house of em it was basically
Bravo's way of saying like here's how
all this of his building it was a story
designed explicitly to demonstrate the
Scarlet Witch was going insane you know
it's like like I said it's the same
thing with Geoff Johns Superman like the
whole reason behind Jeff John Superman
was to give Superman a new ability
that's all it was and then to use that
new ability as a way to take away all of
his powers so nonetheless magic Jasper's
explain will do that at some point in
time and people are kind of trickle in
anything like it's kind of slow like I
thought it'd be more people here um
what's stronger vibranium were
adamantium mmm Paulie adamantium I mean
in the comics adamantium as a whole lot
stronger than vibranium and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe if I bring him to the
strongest metal they have because they
can't use that in a tomb so I haven't
done magic Naspers yet hey Rob can you
tell us what you know about cloak and
dagger actually I don't really know a
whole lot um I don't know much about
cloak and dagger I know of them and I
know that cloak has the ability to
teleport dagger I'm not so sure about
and so I'm I thought about doing some
research on him but in truth they were
never really that compelling to me I was
never really it was it was never like oh
my god you know they're there that
intriguing that I feel like I need to
know about them I just I don't know it's
weird all right Thanos question I read
Thanos annual and infinity revelation no
one the weekly pool included not
commented on the fact that the hint in
it those two stories about how Thanos
avoided the end of 6 16 wet and infinity
revelation on the fact that they hinted
they hinted it in those two stories
about how Thanos of what of the universe
expenses okay here's the deal infinity
revelation as far as I understand
came out after her came out long before
the destruction of the Marvel Universe
and I'm sure Marvel was planning it at
the time but I haven't read anything to
indicate the jim Starlin based this
story on after the end of the multiverse
and so as far as I know infinity
revelation is a totally isolated it's a
rigid graphic novel basically I mean it
literally centers around Adam warlock
and Thanos you know and its really a
story cater to those hardcore fans of
the to mainstream comic fans won't
understand the relationship between the
tube just because it goes back so long
between the whole like Infinity Gauntlet
and Marvel the end and all that kind of
stuff but you know no I mean I don't I
never read I mean that that never
indicated to me that they survived the
collapse of the 616 continuity let's see
so Age of Apocalypse our onslaught angel
apocalypse which we need to finish I
have the script half-finished like I
need to finish it tonight and probably
try to get it recorded the night and
then get it uploaded tomorrow so we'll
see what's up have I been reading The
Secret Wars planet hulk yes the secret
works plan hooks actually pretty good
it's interesting the way it's all
playing out it's going a little bit in a
different direction than I thought it
would and true the story right now just
kind of feels to shuffle it kind of
feels like it's like they're making it
up as they go along which they may very
well be they may not have a plan on what
they want to do with the story but you
know the fact remains that that's pretty
good I mean it's interesting watching
Steve Rogers travel around seeing that
apparently he's been captured by by the
hoax the the hope tribe and that his
devil dinosaurs gone and that the doc
doc Greene I guess dr. Samson whatever
it is version of The Incredible Hulk is
gone so you know that's that's
interesting but let's see was a was
Thanos in Odin's throne room when he
obtained the Infinity Gauntlet no
according to according to either Kevin
foggy or Joss Whedon I cover which one
they said that that there's more than
one infinity Allah because here's the
thing as the infiniti call it's just a
glove like that's all it is I mean it's
literally just a glove that's designed
to house the infinity gems the infiniti
call itself houses no power whatsoever
it's when you put the gems on the
gauntlet that it becomes powerful so you
could probably take the glove of Captain
America and you could put the gyms on it
and say it's the Infinity Gauntlet
anything's at infinity gauntlet it's
just the Infinity Gauntlet Saul ways
been the same thing in Marvel Comics
that's why there's some confusion there
over you know what what makes the
infinity gauntlet powerful so why do you
think they are choosing to use a young
version of Jay Garrick on the next
season of the flash I've always known
him to be older I'm not really sure in
truth of the the age of Jay Garrick
isn't really relevant to me what is
relevant to me is that they're using Jay
Garrick because Jay Garrick started the
flash he's the one that made the flash
popular so you know he's the Golden Age
character I'm glad to see he's there it
would make sense though to use a younger
age younger version because basically
you would mean that it's it's it be a
reflection and in the old flash comics
the Silver Age comics Barry Allen was
older than he is now and so when you had
the story the flash of two worlds you
had Barry Allen and you got Jay Garrick
who were not necessarily the same age
but Jay Kirk was a little bit older the
problem is that if you had a full-grown
Jay Garrick and who had a young Barry
Allen but it would seem as though they
were trying to create a story where jay
garrick's like I have pearls of wisdom
to pass on to you and people just want
to learn they want to see cool stuff
they want to see fun they want to see
action so it makes sense they wouldn't
use an old version of Jay Garrick you
know they would use a younger version of
taker that's more hip and there would be
more interesting but then again you know
he's going to be like Barry how it's
going to be traversing the multiverse
and so there's an infinite number of Jay
Garrick versions so there may be one
where Jay Garrick was super young when
he became the flash instead of being an
older guy but nonetheless you know I
mean it's either way you know I'm
interested to see what direction it goes
in Rob well maestro ever be in the MCU I
doubt it I think the Marvel said that
they're not going to make any more
fantastic or I'm sorry any more
incredible home movies until they secure
the rights to the incredible hulk in his
entire in his entirety and so I think it
makes sense that um that we would stick
with that as a character that we would
stick with the idea of just the
incredible hulk and people aren't really
showing up now are they oh i guess a roo
new rule is not to do comics a coffee at
ten o'clock at night huh
noma there's like like a hundred and
seven people in here but there's like 40
right now but it's all good like it's a
small group of us so I don't mind it um
let's see what age and how do you think
Wally West will come into the flash I
don't know I'm hoping Wally West comes
into the flash as a younger person like
I'm hoping it comes in around the same
age as Barry Allen that way they can
have a lot in common and true they can
really sort of get together and they can
chill and they can do weird stuff I'm
not weird stuff like weird weird stuff
but like I get into all kinds of
nonsense and funny funny moments you
know I'm hoping they do that but then
again it may be Wally West when he's
full grown so I have no idea Jay Garrick
was the result of an experiment that
gave him super speed and that was the
Golden Age explanation and then with as
I guess it's time for breast going into
the Silver Age they gave us a speed
force and I said there is this cosmic
embodiment out there that gives
speedsters or powers and that's pretty
much how they explained it away because
you couldn't have every single person
who develop powers somehow you know just
being the result of an experiment there
had to be something that's hide them all
together even for the sake of just
creating compelling stories and so they
gave us a speed force in order to offset
that which is actually a really smart
idea the biggest now you could use that
as a central point and say all
speedsters that exist in the DC
multiverse draw off this source of
energy so you're hoping for pre 52 wally
west and we'll probably get the pre 52
all the ways i don't know why we
wouldn't i mean but then again i mean
there's nothing to say they won't stick
with a new the problem is that if the
two wally west is hated by a lot of
people not just old-school DC fans but
even like new school DC fans so you
don't really dig it that much so um how
do I feel about Will Smith playing dead
shot I'm fine with it actually I think
will smith will be a great Deadshot I
think I'll be one of the few characters
then we'll be able to keep the film
going on in truth I love the idea of
suicide squad I think Suicide Squad is
going to be a really fun cool film but I
don't think that everybody in that movie
it's going to get the same kind of
attention I think there's going to be
like three or four people who are going
to stand out and of course it's going to
be Will Smith harley quinn the joker and
probably Viola Davis as Amanda Waller
and that's it they're going to be like
the standouts
they're the ones they're gonna be
drawing a big name so we will submit
this drawing the name and because he's
Will Smith Harley Quinn's drawing the
fans in because she's Harley Quinn the
Joker's drawing everybody in because
he's the Joker so you know of course the
way Viola Davis is being portrayed in
and the trailers is going to be pretty
interesting for four people in terms of
like looking at her plus she's got the
whole last show you know how to get away
with murder and I think I think that's
her how to get away with murder could be
wrong but yeah so um let's see how about
ghosts racers have you been reading that
thoughts on it no I avidly avoid all
things go tracer I'm not a huge fan of
ghost racer at all let's see did anyone
else think that in the flash preview
trailer the speedster at the end was the
black flash I don't know I mean I
haven't either actually haven't seen it
yet to be honest what is a DC equivalent
of Marvel unlimited they don't have one
I don't think I don't think DC has a
Marvel unlimited which kind of sucks you
would think they would where they would
be like hey guys there's like all the
stuff but if what you're wanting to do
is basically push your new 52 the best
way to do that is to not have Marvel
unlimited but a better way to get over
Marvel unlimited to do better than
Marvel does is to basically say here's
all of our current stories like right
now and you can just pay like 15 bucks a
month if they charge a little bit more
because right now I was ten bucks a
month from Marvel unlimited but you have
to wait six months for the current
stories if DC came along and they said
will charge you 15 bucks a month and you
can get all the current stories you know
then that would be solid the problem is
with the initial influx offset you know
be the possible profit loss and I think
it would because right now comics are
like four bucks and so you know they
came along and they said it's fifteen
dollars a month I mean that's
considering all the stories it would be
publicised then I mean it kind of varies
you know kind of depends but either way
I mean I would do it I pay fifteen
dollars a month to read all of DC
stories right now digitally online as I
propose having to go out and buy the
trades let's see spider-man is confirmed
for civil war is he like I don't know if
he was actually going to be in it or not
which is kind of weird because you would
think that they would have like a
post-credit scene for spider-man but I
imagine right now they're still trying
to get all that stuff sorted out so I
don't know did you catch the little
easter eggs in ant-man movie
I can't I got a lot of like I mean it
was funny because i saw this article i
think by the huffington post and they
were like hey guys here's a trail that
you most likely miss like the huge
trailer that you missed and it was a
true another trailer the easter egg and
it was about spider-man and somebody
posted a comment below they were like
you would literally have to be deaf in
order to not catch that easter egg and I
was like exactly like of course
everybody got it who wouldn't catch it
but there was just a click bait article
it was just designed to draw people in
this is all it was but um it's ex but
not be too good I expert not me choose
okay um it doesn't feel like x-men the
animated series at least not to me it
doesn't but that's because to me I think
when it comes to creating coming book
versions of like cartoon shows there's
like this this dichotomy we've been
watching me for about 20 minutes there's
like this dichotomy this invisible wall
between you know what I find interesting
and compelling and what I think is you
know not interesting and compelling and
with the whole Expo 92 thing it's cool
it's fun to see like the old-school X
been depicted a comic book form you know
it just looks you know it looks cartoony
it looks like it literally looks like a
cartoon version of x-men the animated
series on you know on a kind of book
form it's just the stories on it's
interesting as i used to be and maybe
it's just because I'm older now but you
know even now I can go back and watch
x-men the animated series and the
stories are still cool but the question
is is that big kind of nostalgia or is
it because the stories are genuinely
cool so I guess kind of leave it to you
guys suicide is old man Logan really
good yes all men Logan's probably the
best full range story ever written like
it is probably the single most important
Wolverines story ever written because it
really it was a story the fans needed i
have a video on why it was so important
but it is it is really really good Tower
of Babel explained I've been wanting to
umm I think I think I really want to do
that I mean I'm going to do a video
probably based on all the forms of
Kryptonite like we're literally just
going to go through and say here are the
forms of Kryptonite here's when they
appeared here's what they do and and
just kind of go from there but I mean
I'd love to do Tower of Babel you know
because it was such a great story it was
it was a really cool concept but see how
would you rank ant-man in the hierarchy
of
Cinematic Universe films a lot of
regular way up there I mean number one
you get iron man like Iron Man's always
going to be my favorite my top film in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe because it
started the Marvel Cinematic Universe I
mean I've got a huge picture of Tony
Stark sitting right here you know which
which reminds me how awesome the the
movie was and of course the Incredible
Hulk because that one just looked cool
but on now for me I would say that that
right at the top is is Iron Man after
iron man it's going into the galaxy then
captain america the winter soldier and
then after that probably the Avengers
and then ant-man and then everything
else no particular order so Rob what is
your favorite DC cartoon show uh hmm it
was probably batman the animated series
for way back in the 90s that show was
was hands down the best show ever let's
see my boys watch all the animated
marvel shows on disney XD and at their
insistence I'm catching up I figured
this is how they are figuring out what
other characters to make I mean well see
here's here's the kicker when it comes
to Marvel making characters and this is
this is I mean I don't know what their
pattern is for making characters I don't
know if they literally just draw things
out of a hat I don't know if a creator
is just sitting there and says let's try
this character but it's been a while
since Marvel I created a new character
that was compelling I mean they've done
it off and on I mean they did it with
the Inhumans I guess you know but in
truth when it comes to making characters
it's trial and error like it's it's just
let's make a character and see how they
received and if they're well received
will keep them going and if not then we
won't you can see that with the Inhumans
you know when Marvel launched in human
it was literally them creating all
different kinds of Inhumans using the
you know the fallout from the from the
Terrigen bomb exploding at the hands of
Black Bolt and you can literally just go
through the Inhumans story and watch
them just create people just create new
characters some of whom were compelling
some of whom people loved some of whom a
didn't some of the villains were dumb
you know some of the story was was kind
of silly but the really funny thing here
is as you go through those stories while
the story itself is ridiculous while the
story itself might be silly or it might
be the greatest story ever people will
latch onto characters they
see a character and then we'll say that
guy's amazing well that woman's amazing
or that thing is amazing whatever it
happens to be and it'll just become a
fan favorite you know I mean that's how
it was with with squirrel girl you know
people ask the question why squirrel
girl so popular well because no one ever
beats her like she always wins but it's
always done off panel you know she's a
she's a joke she's kind of a you know a
prank that constantly goes on in the
realm of Marvel and people love that
people think it's one of the coolest
things and so that's that's why you know
people latch onto her character so well
but um let's see who is the bald guy
who's a bad guy low key or Ultron um
who's the better bad guy low key ultra
low key hands down like Ultron is cool
but Ultron in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe was like pales in comparison to
how awesome Loki was so um made it to
the show for once welcome Rob what did
you start the last year we saw the
livestream at ten-thirty and which
apparently streaming at ten-thirty and
night is not the best time of stream
because unlike like not nearly as many
people show up but that's fun i mean i
don't care i mean it's basically these
these live streams aren't for me to like
garner a million views these live
streams are for me to just like talk to
you guys and answer your questions about
comics so even if I only like ten people
show up and I'll answer questions for
you know until they stop asking or until
an hour hour ends and then and then I'll
bounce off so what do you think Adam
warlock will make his appearance in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe probably with
one of the guardians of the galaxy films
I would say most likely with the
guardians of the galaxy 2 i'm pretty
sure James Gunn is stated that's when
he's going to show up I could be wrong
but I'm pretty sure that's when he'll
pop up you know I mean he says that that
Peter quills father will show up in
guardians of the galaxy 2i think it'll
be star-lord or I'm sorry not star-lord
he's his own dad I think it'll be Adam
warlock debt will show up and so it
release to make sense to me anyway that
it'll be Adam warlock and so so I think
that that will see him then but if we
don't we'll see him sometime between
then and the infinity war series but
then again James Gunn also said don't
expect to see a crossover between the
Avengers and guardians of the galaxy and
so chances are like the Avengers and
infinity war will be the only time we
ever see the two groups meet so i don't
know either way what i do know because i
was thinking about this earlier while i
was making the coffee imagine how funny
would be like an interaction
when Peter quill and iron man like it'd
be it'd be hilarious so um let's see do
you think you will ever explain expand
the complex to explain Brandt a series
from companies outside the big to image
valiant i don't know i mean i'd like to
you the problem is that a lot of their
stories just aren't interesting I mean
you know it's i get there are people who
really really love their stories and i
get there were people who were hardcore
about their stories but that's a very
small number of people and you know as
much as i would like to get into it the
problem is you know do I want to make
videos for a really small niche group of
people or do I want to make videos that
most of my fans are going to enjoy so I
guess I can kind of give it a shot and
see how it feels but I thought that
tired at all no I've got coffee and I'm
gonna start oh crap I thought my cup was
empty and it's not I spilled some coffee
on me well that sucks
now it's empty but um no I i'll probably
do a video do like like you know try
give it a shot with like The Walking
Dead like I want to do a video
explaining like what happens to the
community and the walking dead but uh
but yeah I don't know so I guess I guess
we'll see what happens Rob what's your
opinion of Teen Titans I loved Teen
Titans well the cartoon show I loved
Teen Titans the comics time when I
wasn't that interested in I didn't
really dig him that much the comics were
kind of cool but you know I like the
cartoon show better because to me was
more like appealing it was more
interacting it was more like engaging
you know as opposed to the comic so I
was just kind of like a man whatever but
um let's see do I think that that will
kill anyone I think that knows will kill
a lot of people in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I think you guys have no idea
how many people he's going to kill like
I think I mean not even just wiping out
half a life in the universe I think he's
going to slaughter a bunch of people I
mean they pretty much told us that and
Avengers 2 age of Ultron you had that
premonition from tony stark and we saw a
whole bunch of folks and I so I think
that it will be it'll be pandemonium
it'll be completed in total pandemonium
I think a lot of people are going to get
killed having said that I don't know how
they're gonna bring it back I guess u
infinity gauntlet and restore back to
life but I don't know I guess would be a
way to kind of wipe the slate start over
again that's that's an interesting
concept of ponder but I don't know I'll
Drive myself nuts with those kind of
questions fast comes out of nowhere
where's fast at fast isn't on here is he
where spouse I will see fast on here
anywhere
oh when I saw the Teen Titans were going
I didn't like the Teen Titans you have
faust would pop out of nowhere like what
you say about the Teen Titans like what
how do you said that what I will say is
this I'm reading a reading Starfire solo
series and it's actually really funny
like I am what is Rob why does DC Comics
even they don't hate Superman like be
neat Superman um I was when we were
doing the weekly pool emmalin episode we
were talking about our favorite
colleagues from the secret wars and
marvel's dcu and all that kind of stuff
and faust had stated that he really
loved the near Starfire and that was
kind of sitting on that for a while and
I was like you know maybe I should read
the new Starfire you know because I'm
really enjoying what they're doing with
DC you so far but um you know I was
reading I was thinking you know let's
okay let's let's check out the new star
fire and it's actually really funny it's
really entertaining and so I figured you
know I don't know if anybody's done this
yet but i think i should do a video on
like explaining what is DC you like what
what's DC you um but uh but nonetheless
you know i think that the new Starfire
is hilarious like it's funny because
she's like she takes everything so
literally because she doesn't understand
sarcasm she doesn't understand why
people are the way they are she doesn't
get things and and so like plus like her
own cultural aspects in terms of the
fact that she can learn languages by
kissing people like she randomly kisses
the janitor at their header trailer park
you know it's just funny you know to see
to see those weird situations those
weird I economies but then again you
know it's it's it's interesting so which
villain would you like to see in the new
spider-man film Mysterio definitely like
we had a discussion about this and I
think the last comic Singh coffee that I
did and we had talked about how of all
the characters that were out there in
Marvel Comics that they hadn't made
villains with for spider-man the
mysterium is the most compelling one
like we've seen venom we've seen we seen
the lizard we've seen I guess rhino you
know what's the the bank crappy which is
what I just want to say this that's the
biggest waste of Paul Giamatti that I've
ever seen like you talking about Paul
Giamatti ladies and gentlemen one of the
greatest actors in Hollywood and they
squander his role in amazing spider-man
2 by having him sit in a giant metal
suit with a crappy Russian accent
shooting it's spider-man at the end of
the movie like what a waste of Paul
Giamatti that god it's it sucks to see
Paul Giamatti is an amazing actor i love
i love everything that he's in except
for that so but um but now we've seen
him we've seen you know spider-man go
against a whole bunch of villains over
the course of his spider-man you know
spider-man film series so far but we've
never seen Mysterio and so I've always
wanted to see Miss Syria we've never
seen Craven I've always wanted to see
Craven especially if they gave us like
Cravens last hunt that the Cravens last
hunt is the epitome of diving into
insanity like that's that that's the
story that you read and like you come
out on the other side completely changed
like you'd like you lose a part of
yourself that you just can't get back
it's very very weird and strange let's
see what we can pull make a debate show
like the the one you silent if had about
one more day even if it is even if it
was once a month and we were given
notice so even the chat could provide
informed input it would be great um
that's not it i mean that's that that
was that's we may do it again um you
know right now it's just kind of
something that we do for fun you know so
I'm not doing apology amati by no
impression no way I carnage has to have
venom though yeah the worst part is they
didn't even complete the flight no they
didn't cravers last hunt is the best
friend Amanda story ever in my opinion
it is it's a really good spider-man
story it's just so weird like it's just
so strange like like eating spiders and
it's i don't know i mean it's it's that
story is a descent into complete and
total madness that's how I look at it it
is a descent into complete insanity yeah
let's see they should bring more loon
debt see that would be a cool story it
like the inheritors and stuff the
problem is does Marvel have a story or
does Marvel have the rights to make
movies based on just spider-man or I
guess not really the right does their
agreement allow them to make movies
based on only p
Parker on other versions of spider-man
because they did they make something
solid like I would i mean i wouldn't
mind seeing spider verse sing like Miles
Morales because it would here's a really
cool thing mad spider verse while the
story itself was boring as hell and
while the story itself was was basically
crap in my book like I just didn't like
it at all if Marvel made a movie about
spider verse they could literally test
the waters to see who would who people
would be receptive to they could make
the movie they could release it and then
people would basically say like oh this
is my version of like spider-man this is
my favorite version of this you know and
they could say what Miles Morales was
better or like Gwen Stacy you know
spider groggy guarantee like Gwen Stacy
spider when I would take off and people
would love her you know but but people
would be able to say like these are the
characters I love the most and Marvel be
able to look at the most popular
trending characters from the spider
verse film and then make movies based on
that where Sony could do it you know but
it'd be a great way to test the waters
and to see if they could see how people
would be receptive to spider other
spider characters besides Peter Parker
so let me it's better than simply just
saying like hey let's make a character
about about just good room or make them
with you about Jessica true or see how
that goes like it's that'd be kind of
crazy it's that inspire many where's
your atlantis pro this is the Aspire
Atlantis version to my mini is right
here two totally separate things the
minis not bad though the mini I think
Chuck's better flavor than the Atlantis
but nonetheless like it's it depends
it's all good Rob so are the Inhumans
bound to get a movie we know they're
getting a movie let the movie was
announced to take place between infinity
War part 1 and infinity War part 2 hey
Rob can you do a video on the original
secret wars in the 1980s I'm actually
making a video about that making a
script about that kingdom come explain i
don't know i mean i delight kingdom come
but i don't know god it's just it's such
a huge story like it's so massive um are
you really doing this at night yep yes I
am I told you guys we were going to do
chem loosing coffee I was really tired
earlier today I didn't have the energy
to do it early
junoon so I figured you know I'm gonna
go ahead and do it a night so and I'm
doing it at night and so um let's see
craven has always been a better villain
for spider-man he's more interesting I
don't know if he's a better villain but
he's more interesting let's see what do
you want to see most in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I want to see Adam
warlock and I want to see Adam warlock
portrayed as like a messiah I guess a
messianic character the way he was done
in the comics that being said the way
that we see the vision in age of Ultron
is more like Adam warlock so I don't
know we'll see what happens favorite
vapor flavors definitely well like I
took the cover off this one but
definitely Hobbes blood by the vapor
chef definitely Beeblebrox which is a
tobacco flavor and pretty much any
vanilla custard flavor which by the way
hopefully grants vanilla custard is
going to be selling soon so we'll see
what happens let's see Rob what is your
opinion of the Fantastic Four I think
the Fantastic Four i'm not a brownie and
that's weird my pity of the Fantastic
Four I think the fan has like four were
really relevant back in the day back in
the 1960s when they were basically
bringing in like all these different
people into the marvel cinematic
universe and to the Marvel Comics but
right now you know they're kind of like
not really relevant anymore I mean they
that's the reason why they're going away
I mean it's it's the time of the
Fantastic Four and building up
characters and teams into popularity as
long since gone and the ability for
Marvel to create compelling stories with
the Fantastic Four is long since gone
the last good story from the Fantastic
Four really came out of jonathan
hickman's future foundation and that was
a few years ago so you know I don't I
mean you know before that it was maybe
mark wage run you know before that it
was John Burns run I mean you know it's
you've got like these these huge like
10-year gap between good fantastic four
stories you know i mean it's it's that's
the problem with the Fantastic Four is
is yes they are the you know they are
the original Marvel superhero family
thing are the original superhero team
and yes back in the day they made a lot
of people popular but right now okay
here's my question aside from future
foundation what's the last good
fantastic four story arc what's the last
good story arc
you know i mean that's that's my
question i'm going to listen to when i
say that and i'm going to see if you
guys I'm gonna give you a 30 seconds
let's see
do you take free music for your channel
always definitely Robert uncle boobies
Jefferson
ok
you know and and see that's a funny
thing you know is see somebody said
secret wars I don't know if it's good
but I like the ultimate no not not open
that ultimate like earth-616 Fantastic
Four I see original sin that's not
really a fantastic for cross over the
coming of Galactus Galactus versus
Fantastic Four no one has an answer like
that see that's the thing is is people
are like well I mean you know that's
that's one of the big problems that I
think a lot of people have with with
marvel comics or with with something
like like do I suck or do I blow I don't
do either but I do ban so there you go
anyway now I think that that people are
just like oh my god Fantastic Four like
the Fantastic Four are amazing you know
what why I mean well you know because
you know because they're they're the
original superhero team that's that's
that's the issue I think that people
have is is they know of the Fantastic
Four you know and if you're not
consistently reading fantastic four
stories or marvel comics in general you
know anybody that's been reading marvel
comics for the last 20 years will tell
you the Fantastic Four have not been
relevant for a long time you know
they're in stories and they do some
stuff but they're completely unimportant
you know they're completely not relevant
they're completely just you know they're
just they're you know they're there for
posterity sake narrow the reminder that
at one point in time they had relevance
but now it's just like noon there you
know it's whatever but um you know I
think that that that at the end of the
day you know them going away the fact
that Marvel's kind of cutting them loose
and the fact that they're really only
that many people who were up in arms
really speaks for itself it really
speaks volumes so this man this monster
uh let's see Rob they have a rock man
yes they do ultimate Fantastic Four are
you going to be doing a script on Batman
being a god what are you talking about
that man being a god you see in the 2006
2000 a fantastic for show no and I don't
want to would you like to see dr. doom
in the MCU yes I would love to see dr.
dreams he dr. doing was a saving grace
in the Fantastic Four like the the books
of doom written by Ed Brubaker were so
good
they were amazing and it was fun
watching them it was I guess it was fun
reading them because it gave you the
whole story of dr. doom and then at the
end you realize it's not actually dr.
doom it's a life model decoy of dr.
Doris I guess one of the doom bots for
dr. doom and so that that was a cool
concept but you know the fact remains
that you know is beta way we're going to
be in Thor 3 I don't know the fact
remains that dr. doom is really what
kept the Fantastic Four relevant you
know the Fantastic Four relat were
relevant because dr. doom was popular
and dr. doom in a fantastic for go hand
in hand I mean they're they're villain
other rivalry goes back to the beginning
of the Fantastic Four and so you know
that's to me that's what kept them
relevant if dr. doom had been killed off
and marvel comics for example the fat
has the court would cease to be
important nobody would really think
about them I mean you could you could
look at their stories you know you could
go through and and and go through their
entire you know like all the sales
basically there's other volumes and see
that they were just decreasing going
down and down and down and down over
time so the Superman flies into the Sun
for 25 million years and becomes god of
sorts oh you're talking about Superman
the end like it okay I thought you said
Batman Batman the god you're talking
about Superman like Superman 1 million
so I understand what you're talking
about let's see Batman is now in control
of the Mobius chair on the latest issue
of Darkseid war they have a red dockside
war yet I need to get into it people are
saying that like it's it's pretty solid
okay I have to check that out then so um
who do you think would win if Deadpool
win against Superman and goku vs
Superman ooh Deadpool would definitely
go against would see look somebody some
guys in the in the gaylord chaotic I
like every everybody noticed that guy
everybody noticed that guy like
everybody say hey Gaylord chaotic like
what's up and then the whole okay here's
a reason that's what I'm gonna start
doing from that one like anytime anybody
gets into the end of the comments that
starts trolling i think i'm going to
direct everybody's attention to them and
here's the reason why people get on the
internet and they troll because for
whatever reason their life sucks I mean
maybe maybe their girlfriend is banging
another guy you know maybe they're in a
marriage and they hate their wife and
kids you know
be there sitting in a cubicle wasting
eight hours out of their day but for
whatever reason they hate their lives
and the only way for them to find any
relevance in their lives the only way
for their life to matter is to try to
make other people's lives miserable and
and I don't know i mean let's listen
okay so let's talk about this for a
second i mean it's when you get past
that and you you look at the nature of
of people who are trolls like like it
sucks you know it sucks for them as
people you know because you're talking
about individuals who live lose lives
like don't matter I mean whose lives
like don't don't have any value and
that's a problem you know because people
will hear me say that and they will say
like oh my god you know like Rob you're
such a jerk you know or they'll scoff it
off they like off whatever you know my
life's important my life has meaning but
here's the kicker at the end of the day
when that Gaylord you know Gaylord
chaotic chaotic guy when he when he goes
to bed when he lays down at night you
know he may very well forget about me
may work very well come in here and
troll whatever and then you know when
he's done he'll he'll go to sleep but at
that moment right between the time that
he closes his eyes and falls asleep he's
going to think back to exactly what I'm
saying now and he's going to know that
I'm one hundred percent right when I say
that that guy does not serve a purpose
in life so anyway God now I got to start
banning people yeah I mean trolls are
funny to me you know because it's it's I
mean all that I think about like
whenever I see people getting on my
channel and I'm trolling is that they're
mad because they're not me so Rob the
fan has like four don't basically don't
have that many amazing adversaries maybe
they should introduce a new villain well
that's a problem you know i mean the
Fantastic Four or are these these
characters you know there's these people
that have that had relevance you know
but with dr. doom is their only real
significant adversary it's not important
you know it's not
it's not relevant to them i mean it's
it's a guy who shows up that's more
important that the superheroes that he's
fighting against it's more interesting
than the superhero is he's fighting
against and so you know i don't i don't
know either way you know they're people
like man that's heavy yeah no I'm just
I'm just saying man on this it's like I
know I'm right I know I'm right like
it's that's that's a sad thing is is
people get in and people troll and they
they you know they cause problems you
know and and it's it's because for
whatever reason like their life sucks
you know and and they won't admit it to
themselves they won't be like yes my
life sucks you know there's like no I'm
just having fun I'm much more like like
that guy is like i'm not trolling like
that guy's one hundred percent trolling
and he's trolling because his life his
life is empty and his life is void you
know and and he may have a wife where he
may have a you know if it's a woman you
know she may have a husband you know but
whatever the reason is you know their
life is crap and i know that because
people who enjoy their lives are out
enjoying their lives throughout having
fun like they're making videos on
youtube for people they're doing live
you know to an eight sessions they're
going shopping at the mall you know
they're they're having sex you know i
mean they're they're enjoying their
lives you know they're not getting on
the internet and giving other people
crap and so that's how I know that guy's
life sucks so Arnold own eyes I can see
you fun but do you I think the Deadpool
movie will be good I think they tentpole
movies going to be amazing and truth I
think the Deadpool movie is going to be
the best movie of next year like I think
it's gonna be the best movie of 2016
because it one is rated R which means
we're going to see an insane amount of
violence an insane amount of cussing you
know but to it's gonna be dead pool and
so you know I I think that with the
whole the Micra my favorite new 52 title
is definitely Superman's current run um
I think with the whole you know I think
with the whole Deadpool thing we're
going to see the definitive Deadpool in
movie form with this plus like Ryan
Reynolds is a huge Deadpool fan we
basically have a Deadpool fan making the
quintessential Deadpool movie it's it's
like Kevin foggy taking over the mono
Cinematic Universe like you know
I'm i think i think it's i think it's
awesome you know i think i think it's
going to be the best movie of the year
so what are your thoughts on the
Ghostbusters reboot I am so excited the
cast looks hilarious like I'm really
hoping that like we get a couple cameos
from some of the old school guy I mean
well I mean you know we won't see Harold
Ramis because he passed away which sucks
you know I think Bill Murray and Dan
accorded the only ones left we might see
Harold are not Harold Ramis well might
we might see Rick Moranis you know but I
think aside from that you know it'll be
it'll be interesting you know um it'll
it'll be the most entertaining but Cathy
would be better I don't know see I've
what I will say is this even if they're
not going to be the even if they're not
going to be it's apples and oranges
Deadpool might be better than Captain
America 3 Captain America 3 might be
better than Deadpool but what I do know
is this next year is going to be full of
coloring book movies and it's going to
be amazing so you know regardless of who
you'd like more there's going to be so
much content out there and there's going
to be similar stuff to see plus we have
the Netflix series coming out so I'm
gonna be really excited for it Rob would
you like an ET tu no um in fact I heard
that um that there was there was talks
to make Steven Spielberg come back to
produce a second EP movie but he didn't
want to and so what he did is he wrote a
script that was so crappy that they
dropped the idea and they said we're
never going to make this movie I think
when something like ET comes back and
starts killing people I can't remember
but but it was it was designed to be
written so bad that the movie studios
were like we're never going to make this
like it was basically sabotaging it so
um no dude seriously I can't watch the
poll on twitch sometimes so I watch it
on your channel which is awesome but
will you keep posting it yeah we'll keep
posted up the problem is is there's so
much coming up right now um so yeah
we'll look at it online um oh crap in
fact I think I might have actually
deleted now that I think about it I may
have to try to find a way to redownload
it but nonetheless yeah I mean if you
guys want I mean you guys should know
you can guys can go back you don't you
know you don't necessarily have to be
there exactly when it's being
broadcasted for whatever reason you're
working or if you're sleeping or
something like that you can go back and
watch it on
like you can go back and watch as a as
an archive broadcast at any point so can
you explain vaping how should you start
getting into it oh um by something
called an ego twist and then by
something called a protank mini from
there get the juice that you love and
you're set that's really all you mean
Rob so
cool I appreciate it do you think hope
will kill Thanos in infinity ward no I
think hoax gonna get his ass kicked in
an infinity war um I think mmm she
answer question who's going to be fan of
us like that's my question Rob what is
your opinion of goku vs Superman we'll
get into that here in a second um which
by the way I want to do a video
answering ScrewAttack but I don't know
because it would have to be equally as
complicated and be weird but CN in the
Infinity Gauntlet event nebula strip
Thanos I was Infinity Gauntlet and kind
of went crazy at the same time but they
just set the stage for nebula doing that
because if you remember in guardians of
the galaxy they made it clear that
nebula was his favorite daughter and she
recognized that going into it and she
was kind of pissed about it and Thanos
was you know that basically didn't
really seem to care about her that much
that right there would set the stage for
for the idea of you know her taking the
Infinity Gauntlet at the end of the
series what a little actually happen or
not is a totally different argument but
you know unless I think it'll be pretty
solid let's see do you believe the
character of the Hulk is more of a
sidekick now not at all hoaxes known
story I'm he says he's his own main
superhero that being said they've
written some pretty cool stories about
the Hulk um I get you consider like Rick
Jones to be a sidekick but not
necessarily I mean he's a bomb now is
what he calls himself a stupid man while
he's dead now so I guess it doesn't
matter that no I'm not in California um
but now I mean it's a hoax about a
sidekick for anybody you know it's hoax
nobody's [ __ ] let's see do you wish the
MCU is more serious or are you okay with
how it is now I think I'm fine with how
it is now because it's a great
combination of serious movies and
comedic movies yeah I mean you know
ant-man was a great comedy and it was a
great comedy because it's offsetting
like its comedy is going to offset
what's about to happen and Captain
America Civil War so that's that's a
great I think that what they're doing is
fine i mean the balancing you know funny
movies with dark movies you know and
that I think is if somebody that needed
to happen then I think is something that
needed to take place so
let's see do you think Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine will be killed in a film yes I
think they're going to kill him with old
man Logan I think they're going to get
rid of him with old man Logan I think
they're going to end the hugh jackman
wolverine run and we're not going to see
him coming back as well rain anymore
that being said Wolverines not going to
die entirely I think they're gonna bring
somebody else back they're going to say
oh it's kind of like a separate
Wolverine I don't know but nonetheless
you know it we'll see what happens let's
see what's what's old man Logan old man
Logan was a story that centered around
will rain in a different reality where
he had killed the entire roster of the
x-men under the illusion of Mysterio and
the result was at at the same time there
was a campaign by the villains of the
Marvel Universe to band together and
kill all the superheroes at the same
time and so the result was that it
created this dystopian future where all
the superheroes were dead except for
Wolverine incredible was insane he
banged she hulk they had kids which was
weird and then those kids had kids and
so on and so forth but um let's see you
don't like apocalypses makeup okay let's
talk about this guy's let's listen let's
talk about yeah i think the Megalodon
shark exist let's talk about the whole
apocalypse thing you know because
because we're going to be winding this
down here in the next 10 minutes or so
so let's talk about you know apocalypse
yes apocalypse looks like poop like he
looks like poo it looks it looks pitiful
not even the sense that he's purple he's
really not purple because people are
saying oh well it's the light they're
cast on the purple whatever i agree i
doubt that storms going to be the color
purple and the x-men apocalypse film
having said that apocalypse is supposed
to be menacing he's supposed to be
imposing like not necessarily you know
physically scary-looking but he's
supposed to be imposing he's supposed to
be a person that is is like you know
overbearing he's supposed to look at the
iu you're so you're supposed to look at
the character of apocalypse and be like
oh my god like this this dude means
business and i think that you know we
may see that you know we may see that
overbearing you know version of
apocalypse but for right now like he
looks the same as ever
he looks the same size as everybody else
now again that doesn't mean that we're
not going to see that version of
Apocalypse we may see that in the final
battle apocalypse grows so like 300 feet
tall you know and just start smashing on
people and we have no idea you know he
may very well you know change his shape
and give himself up our flight grow
wings or turn his arms and a crazy
things and so on all that kind of stuff
you know but at the moment you know he
the reason why people are getting so
freaked out for those of you guys who
aren't added comic book readers those of
you guys who don't consistently read
Marvel Comics the reason why so many
people are getting freaked out over the
idea that apocalypse doesn't look the
same is because so many people love the
character apocalypse he is he was
everybody's favorite villain an ex been
the animated series we knew that if
apocalypse showed up the story was going
to be cool you know apocalypses you know
him Lou along is along the lines of his
head you know that surrounded his lips
and went up into his and it was a design
that signature like that is signature
apocalypse you know he's always had that
look you know even when he was killed
and resurrected the form of a kid he had
that he had a facial appearance is a a
trade bloc of his character it ties into
the history of Apocalypse in the sense
that he was always shunned by people
because of his physical appearance you
know it's an ingrained part of his
character it defines him it's what makes
him who he is you know to see that kind
of stripped away is you know is is
really worrisome to a lot of people not
only that people you know one it's a fox
x-men film and so people are already a
little bit leery because Fox has a
really good habit it has a really bad
habit of screwing up x-men characters
and teams and so people look at this as
just another example of Fox doesn't know
what they're doing like Fox watched XP
in the animated series and they decided
to make a movie based on apocalypse you
know or something like that or somebody
at Fox you know read like a single
apocalypse comic and said I know
everything about the character let's go
with it and and they're making a film
accordingly you know that's the
perception people have a fox that that
they are that they are a coffee maker
making you know I don't know making wine
that they're there they have no business
doing what they're doing they don't know
what they're doing
you know in the end I think it'll come
out to be pretty solid you know I would
just like to think that the version of
Apocalypse that we see in these previews
is not really the way he's going to look
that you know he'll be a far more
imposing character in the movie itself
right now it was too early to judge you
know that's why I'm not really taking
the stance of saying like the movies
going to be garbage I was suddenly just
saying apocalypse looks like crap like
he looks goofy looking like he looks
like diving news you know and and I
think that you know once everybody comes
out then we can pass judgment but the
ones who are out there you know doom and
gloom oh my god maybes going to blow the
movies going to suck it's gonna be
awfully also on those people like that
always say that like anytime there's any
variance like like they want to see a
movie that's a reflection of their
favorite part of the comic and if it
doesn't have that that the movie sucks
which is a silly notion but nonetheless
you know um I'm is far beyond that's
that's what I want to hear I want to
hear that at some point in the film I
want to hear apocalypse ya'll say like
like you know and I'm as far beyond
mutants as they are beyond you you know
or or you know I'm as far beyond mutants
as you could ever dream or something
like that you know that I think would be
really cool but let's see dr. doom
versus the beyonders see we all know I
mean we know that he killed to the
honors we just don't know how well at
least we know molecule man Doctor
Strange and Doctor Doom kill to be on
which we just don't know how they did
that you know it's it's you know it's
crazy so yeah how much the coffee moves
pretty fast but that's fine I'll catch
you later man let's see wolverine vs The
Punisher Netflix miniseries I would
watch that i would so watch that ooh be
amazing let's see Oscar Isaac is above
this version of apocalypse Oscar Isaac
is about a lot of things like I'm
surprised he even agreed to do this I
don't know I thought that Oscar Isaacs
was going to be like I'm not doing
apocalypse I mean you got me Oscar Isaac
she's an amazing actor you know
especially after ex machina you know
he's solid with that film and so I mean
it'll be cool because it'll give him a
chance to kind of you know blow up and
do his own thing but you know the fact
remains that it's weird you know seeing
that let's see instead hold a moment and
never answered
uh let's see Rob can you please do do me
a simple favor and there's gonna be a
ridiculous favor what about the upcoming
Thanos deadpool comic what do you think
who do you think will win deaths hand
Deadpool probably will Thor ever wake up
I don't know that he's asleep unless
you're talking about waking up and
realizing that he's in this battle world
which he is because he's been telling
people that let's see he will be great
in Star Wars I don't know you talked
about what you do God loves man kills
Rob probably not i mean that stories
that's a super old story it's good but
it's an old-school story a man sucks who
agrees on no one no one agrees with you
let's see Man Thing ghost rider blade
werewolf by night team up netflix series
why in god's name would you want to make
a team-up series based on those
characters werewolf by night I mean come
on man Rob are you ready for the power
years reboot in 2016 yes I've heard they
wanted to do it I know it was confirmed
but I am definitely down to see a Power
Rangers reboot anyway guys we're going
to bounce off here I need to work on a
script for the Krypton thing for the aid
rupocalypse for for the case in support
of iron man for civil war and the case
in support of Captain America for civil
war so anyway um I want to go ahead
bounce off your guys thanks for coming
out for this live Q&A session and I will
catch you guys later peace